you were the Justin Bieber of 1991 how
does that make you feel real good now
listen I really thought that was a cute
reaction that Luke add to his comparison
to me because I didn't think about it he
really kind of was more the other way
around
what'd you think Jason and Bieber are
more so the comparison Jason first okay
yeah Jason came first so Bieber's more
like Jason exactly okay often imitated
never duplicated that is very true
nihlus and we are in a very special
place right now here at the pop-up we
are in the booth that is dedicated to
Luke Perry I know you guys think about
him often there's not a day goes by that
you don't think about him and that you
keep his memory alive I'm sorry I just
can't control myself
don't fight it Luke was to just sort of
you know quiet subtle yet dynamic human
being he had a very strong and lasting
impact on people you and I have been a
lot of things to each other over the
years Kenneth there are moments when
it's easier than others you know what I
my still haven't thought of it going
little LaBeouf he was a beautiful humble
gentle kind thoughtful so Luke suffered
a massive stroke on February 27 and
passed away five days later he was
surrounded by his two children his
fiancee his ex-wife and his mom we miss
him every day there's a huge pool in our
hearts and everyone's hearts with him
gone it's ironic the role that made him
a star almost wasn't his Luke was
originally supposed to audition to be
Steve Sanders but didn't feel he was the
right fit for the part on screen the
then 24 year old was brooding and
confident off-screen he was actually
kind of shy personal life is very
valuable to me and the only thing I'm
finding difficult is a little less
privacy you know people know who you are
you just don't know who they are you
don't see them on TV fame was never the
goal I'm in no hurry to have my name
above the title to be the star of a film
then when the time comes I feel a little
more comfortable
next year from the 902 uh no set to red
carpets we spend hundreds of hours with
Luke it was clear he loved his craft and
adored his fans he was honest and
charming what works for me is just try
to keep the to a minimum
don't lie to him and don't go out of
your way to give him anything right
about you've just got gotten married
recently don't you kind of want to like
hang out with your wife and do husbandly
things yeah but you know I don't know
what those husbandly things would be
even after his divorce in 2003 Luke
remained friends with his ex he was a
devoted parent to his two children lived
life to the fullest and had no regrets
life is experiential do you got to get
out there and you got to try it and you
got to fail sometimes and to get to any
success you got to fail a few times and
so yeah I think you gotta run
[Music]